[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
with the witcher franchise CD Projekt
have gone from strength to strength in
seven short years but can this little
team from poland create the masterpiece
they've been flirting with well we pony
up the cash and flew across the world to
find out next week on gamespot 3
features detailing everything you need
to know about the witcher 3 wild hunt a
game that could easily be the biggest
hit of 2015 in part 1 for newcomers and
veterans alike we introduced Wild Hunt
the witcher was really a place where we
could unleash our all of our creativity
in part 2 we detailed the vast world of
the witcher in game development people
make the mistake of creating the village
first than the landscape and in part 3
we unveiled the quests combatting
gameplay of
I know it might feel irritating when you
level and six or five and the encounter
level 4 d2 quest I think this is
something that players will come back to
later on in the game plus we got this
really sick filter that makes it look
like we're in communist Poland so for
exclusive gameplay new details candid
interviews and everything you need to
know about one of the most exciting
games of 2015 join us next Monday
Tuesday and Wednesday on gamespot com
[Music]